[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
true
[Music]
[Music]
call me asia and teddy poodle
hey everyone i'm aishah a variety
streamer based in the netherlands a
mother of three kids and type 1 diabetic
i'm a huge fan of management and
simulation games but don't ask me how i
manage my life with three kids because i
honestly don't know
hi i'm david vinnie i'm a wholesome
writer streamer from the uk
i love to scream i love to laugh and i
bring the fun vibes to any game did she
say awesome
i did
and i'll say it again
um
and some people describe me as chaotic
but i like to might call myself streamer
[Music]
my name is asia that's what you can call
me i am a photographer videographer and
gaming content creator who focuses on
helping people live brighter lives and i
am really excited to be here
hello beautiful humans i am teddy poodle
your favorite adhd first person shooter
streamer and i'm here to keep the cozy
and the chaos
how's everyone doing right here
i'm good excited
i'm ready
i'm so terrified but i'm ready
hey daddy poodle what's evil
so evil is a multiplayer game similar to
first class troubles and a manga so if
you played any of those games you're
gonna enjoy this one so up to 12 players
can enter the village of evil together
but not everyone who you know who they
say they are you got some sneaky people
out there trying to
cause some
trying to cause some chaos you look
you're starting already look at that um
and it's your job as a villager to
actually find out who those conspiracies
are so you can
get them out of there
see and what's really unique about evil
is that every role or each player gets
every it gets a new role and every role
has specific abilities and talents now
this is my favorite part of the game evo
works with a day and night cycle during
the day all players are active but
during the night all villagers have to
be in bed and leave their necks
unattended for me to get to them i said
what i said
now
anyone can be a conspirator um and if
you are you just need to take out your
opposition
um there are some conditions that do
need to be met but you also get some
perks as well
so yeah you pretty much have to
eliminate the enemies without getting
caught
so some people may have been talking
about you there's snitches there's ops
as you can see around me
so when you get into the town meeting
make sure that you commit to the story
and have the poker face ready otherwise
someone will set you up
it's i just i feel like i was really
targeted but it's fine it's fine we
don't want to spoil too much but we can
tell you that it's coming evil it's
coming to pc playstation and xbox so you
can put evil in the chat for more info
and don't forget to add it to your wish
list
alrighty y'all let's get evil
let's kill
okay
so
let's kill
know very yay
very reflections the the actions of me
and game is not a reflection of me as a
character thank you
service announcement just so you know
right let's just go ahead
i'm warmed up
no timing for warming up we warmed up
that's not fair
[Music]
i think sneaking off the randomize was
just for choosing your alias yes yeah it
would be crazy to be like oh it was
it'd be long stuck oh my gosh we should
have all changed
wow
that would have been so silly
okay okay
okay i'm to do my where's my house at me
okay i just checked my face
oh my god
now i'm going ahead and find my first
quest so i can earn
yeah
how do you know which one is your house
is it based on something is your color
oh it's based on your color it's your
color
okay
so i'm like
yeah so your house is gray that's that
dark gray
thingamabobber
yeah so you just have to look at your
name color and that's the exact same
color
really ok button
i'm trying to figure out my tears
oh really okay
okay then pretend it's me
now let me go oh yeah i see like the
game okay you know what let's try this
again because if i get to particular i
do want to get grinny you know
we're leaving
yeah i'm
you know this is wild to me good because
i was the killer i didn't want to be one
i'm driving
my hopes rating my heart was bleeding so
fast
i'm gonna go ahead and make a lobby
right now okay okay okay
i'm gonna have to tell you i'm not
awesome yeah
you wanna you're trying to get me though
i mean
i'm just playing the game
mom
okay the lobby is about to be up and
it's the same password
okay okay
i think my heart was going so fast
i'm innocent
i can't wait i really want to be it
it's nice it's really nice being uh
you know having having the power
yeah i got asia in here
yeah i'm just jumping in
yes
we
go
yeah
jk
i can learn how to type oh it's the
password different no no it's the same
perfect
everybody twice because that's what
happened
it'd be like that sometimes
yeah
so what i really like so far is that the
map doesn't feel
stale is that a good word to use like i
feel like
i get excited to find more things
like once i actually know the map i feel
like i'll
be really comfy with like getting quests
done right now i feel like really
overwhelmed because
every single time we played i have done
zero quests
yeah i just
i really like the arrows on the ground
because i yeah if those errors were not
there i would definitely get lost
yeah
i think it's just i mean it's like any
of the other games like among us
you have to like get used to the the map
right
so it just takes just some playing
really
well i do like the fact that they've got
the arrows and they've got the tasks and
stuff so right you also ping on the map
too
like if you go to like the town hall
mm-hmm you can go on a map and you can
ping different areas which i think is
really cool
yeah oh they'll show your map i i
believe so but we can try it out oh yeah
let's see if somebody doesn't kill me
[Laughter]
don't set us up because you might be the
barbarian next
wow
i don't want to be
the barbarian is i like the whack-a-mole
though
okay so we got almost everyone in here
who are we missing i'm here oh i'm here
i'm ready every guy i'm here is everyone
ready up maybe
let's see
my
so one of the things that came up and
i didn't have before because i was a
civilian before the last one was a
villager so then you could like put
traps to ready for the night
that's yeah for preparation yeah yeah
but then you have to weigh that against
doing your quests
right exactly
yes okay here we go so many rolls my
goodness i know this is better there are
so many
it's different i love it
okay
we should be looking at each other's
faces
[Music]
see i don't like this creepy man face
this is all this is it's but listen
listen
yo
that's messed up y'all just jealous of
the drink it's okay
your way on the back
okay let's see i'm gonna start my first
question right now because daytime
doesn't last long it only lasts like
one minute it's only 40 seconds yeah
then it's about to be night
oh my god
where do i go is that there's always a
countdown over as well
that's the amount of time you have
before it turns into night
i like that
i promise i'm not the person but i like
that
like you have the same task
yeah that's cool oh it doesn't it
doesn't like it's cool i've got i've
done that
like in my house
i'm just going to follow the hair room
i'm going to get lost with this here we
go
hey bite this
i've done my first press okay
from fishing oh period
okay
no
let's go after i'd get distracted i'd
just be doing the
i got some money there you go oh i get
the keeper
hello
oh yeah
oh no don't look nice i have enough time
okay where's the phone
okay i'm scared we've got 10 seconds
there's a second
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh this is so scary oh my god oh
my god
do you not
if i if whoever it is doesn't kill me
i'll give you money i'll give you money
what money i'm just trying to say i'm
going to pay my way out of this
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i need to read more info about the final
guy
they got the potions
there isn't somebody up here oh that's
it depend no i'm at the trade shop am i
trying to find my drinks
oh
okay
oh wait wait wait am i going in the
right direction
i don't think so wait who's following me
oh here we go
can you have two entrances to your house
[Music]
your next quest
yeah i just found it
what is so big
i don't have an extra mushroom salad you
know but you can buy some a defender
right
oh yeah you can
i can't
earn my way you know
i'm
[Music]
she's like always right behind me for
some reason
[Music]
okay
i need y'all to trap my house for me
please revise your house
right in front of my door oh i wonder if
he's going to be the first to give me
five people's services who's going to be
i'll give you five coins or a trap what
[Music]
you can stay away from me and see i got
full health and i intend to keep it that
way
oh
oh we can't see where other people are
either okay
[Laughter]
are you late
really
[Music]
you can do them right now
she can't come in no no
if you're not here you can't come in
it's clink clink lockdown over here
absolutely not
i called this meeting because no one is
dead someone was late though so that's a
little saucy
okay
okay
you know
i fight for ready
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
i've never been so stressed in my life
bro please oh my god
[Music]
it felt right at the time
oh my god oh no i don't know where these
things are they've mocked her houses
like the death house as well
ghost let me talk to you where are you
i'm the ghost whisperer
who are you let me see your ghostly
stuff what do you want to talk to her
about she got murmured
let me tough literally
where are you
[Music]
[Music]
how many more to go
i can't believe you guys actually heard
something
why did we subscribe
i didn't think anyone i was no
petty as hell that's what was happening
oh wow well
at least now we have fewer people
now sure
okay and no one's died
i feel like we've got a positive killer
oh positive killer
killer i mean that is a tactic where you
can
me see how much money do i have i need
to do more tasks i need yeah
i'm not i'm stuck on i'm trying to find
the machine
there he is again me too i have no idea
what this is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
leave it there
even the way that you were taken out was
basically something this is the
because i'm supposed to find something
interesting
yeah i'm going up to my next thing
i can't believe i spent all that time oh
no oh no i gotta go back home
wait a minute
wait a minute
i'm not looking for a school i can't
find it
oh my god this is really ghetto that we
have to make
the stuff for an antidote
and i'm sleeping again
okay
[Music]
this game is letting me sleep more than
i actually sleep irl right
you're sleeping what is happening
let me get all my uh beauty sleep real
quick
here we go
listen don't bring your docky self there
right really what actually are you doing
you're dead what are you up to why
you're not
so basically i'm still being passed
and one of my tasks was to speak people
ha
oh
right spooking people i've just got i've
done it i've scooped three people oh i
have to do that
redeem whatever i get i forgot to do
what i was supposed to do thank you i'm
so sorry this has happened for you no
you are not cassie you orchestrated this
hello
i don't know what this is in front of my
house
i think it should be here let me let me
try and dig it out does anyone know how
you're getting your backpack
with a b b okay if you press b you're
getting your backpack
all right all of the air i'm just taking
a random stuff that i see at this point
because
hello make sure you at least keep
spacing your back
hello i'm just trying to get
i'm sure
what is this afterlife
[Laughter]
[Music]
after like ate all that man
here
i hope you
brought me here better than the real
life we have this brother is because
you're not here
you need to try places really
okay so complete i got more
[Music]
um
i feel like the easiest thing was
following
i was
[Music]
i need night to be over
i got money to earn i'm sick
five seconds this kid was really nice i
know we about to win the music if it was
me i would have killed everyone
[Music]
it like right above your quest
all night
yeah yeah
oh okay
um
there we go
let's see
there you go
[Music]
um okay you got the post i've been
talking to some ghosts
i'm just trying to run away oh oh oh oh
well what's that mushroom what just
happened i i just announced my rule
but don't believe everyone somebody be
lying press one
then two to uh to say who you think is
the conspirator
screaming in my ear like this look at it
how do i i need to find this
um
like if you've got too many things in
your gym red
i feel like i've been on i feel like
i've been doing the same thing for the
most
most thing
see yeah
[Music]
we're supposed to be dying right
oh here it is oh i just took fall damage
oh really
is this the last round i'm scared
well i see we have a golden uh like a
gold star or something next to the right
is that to escape
i'm not leaving my house don't come in
here what's happening
yo is everyone i see someone breaking
their health
where
is it
unknown
call them eating oh
oh i know you know what i don't think it
is i stepped into my own trap
no
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh please hold on what
i don't know what is going on
um
i was like oh what's this mystery called
the light but it was my cat
missed the camera that's a father image
are you dead
i'm innocent
where's the town hall again i'm scared
right people be scared i need a chest
is there a way to recognize the tunnel
on the map
oh no never found it
yeah i see it how's it going oh it's on
the other side
i see the issue here
there we go
but can i use this even if i'm not a
killer
all right so what can we play this on
what can we do for work
what can they play this one
currently
yeah where did it where is it coming
from because it's coming out soon
yes
[Music]
this used to be a quiet peaceful place
these days
no one is safe
not even in their own homes
and the conspirators are to blame
they lurk in the shadows and strike
when nobody's watching
all hope is not lost
each one of you possesses remarkable
skills that will aid in your quest for
justice special abilities that not only
help you uncover the conspirators but
also prove your innocence
you will have to trap spy and even kill
but some of you
won't be so lucky
you must work together and find the
conspirators hiding in plain sight with
the information you've gathered cast
your vote to eliminate the reekers of
havoc
and restore order to evil
[Music]
[Music]
hey you know what a good guess actually
to loan gus glow and ghostbuster i see
you over there uh it starts right now
and it started a half hour ago this
is id at xbox i'll be your host okay
adrian
i really really hope you love indie
games because we got a bunch to show off
big shout outs to everyone over at black
girl gamers for showing off evil game
looks fantastic a lot of chaos going on
i i personally love chaos it's exactly
what i need for equilibrium so you're
here right now and we're going to have a
bunch of game trailers we're speaking to
people who know how the games operate
high pods of war i see you down there
hello we'll be having some gameplay
demos as well i'll be playing one and
i'm
we'll see how it goes i'm decent at
games okay we'll be joined by developers
it's gonna be a really really good time
i hope you're pumped for all this action
now chat as you know
the best part about being on twitch is
that it's interactive right like you you
can go anywhere and just watch a video
but we're live right now that's why i
can live react to all of you right now
you are part of this experience so
please make sure that you send your
thoughts you sent your questions you
share your comments in chat
as long as it's appropriate if you know
what i mean because they'll be stricken
if they're not and we'll highlight them
or show them off or we'll speak about
them because you are part of this show
as well and chat as you may or may not
know
all the shows on twitch gaming are
co-streamable so if you're watching
right now you want to vibe with your own
chat and you're like oh i wish i could
do this too you can
just go ahead and do that
code stream with your own chat your own
channel and talk about all the wonderful
things happening today at id at xbox for
all the new games demos the developer
interviews all this it's gonna be like
amazing i promise you i would not lie to
you and if i did i apologize ahead of
time
also for future events please make sure
that you mark your calendars because the
xbox tokyo game show will be streaming
on september 15th at 6 pm jst
or 2 a.m pacific if you happen to be up
that early which is 5 a.m e-s-t e-t
we'll call et for now so that's what
we're going to do then so make sure you
look forward to all that
now we're going to be showing off a
bunch of trailers of new games as i keep
telling you because i want to hammer
that home indie games are just so
fascinating and wonderful we've had a
wonderful amount spread out this entire
year they're all bangers
but some of these brand new games we're
gonna be showing off will be available
on xbox game pass
and that's the good stuff right we love
having our game packs and saying oh my
god there's nothing to play
and the next thing you know you're like
oh i forgot i have xbox game pass so the
good news is we actually have a set of
trailers to show off
for
games just like that
so do you want to see some trailers
yeah all right cool good feedback
take a look first package
[Music]
my
restore the range from the clutches of
the miasma
[Music]
grow and discover new plant life
[Music]
cultivate an ever-growing garden
find and master magic spells
sustain your sanctuary
discover what makes a home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
yeah
give me two more
like give me more of that
give me more of that like everybody
loves to do like telltale series right
people fall in love with the entire
storyline and have their favorite
moments so of course we're all on board
for that right and graphics becca i see
you in chat right now the bitcon i need
that yeah i need that as well because
one of the little comments in the speech
bubbles said
why is the store always so crowded and
that's me
that's why i do my grocery shopping at
like 2 a.m if i can i don't want people
around me so i know exactly how that
feels uh homestead arcana looks really
cool too
i i don't want to say what game it
reminds me of but anytime i can walk
around any
terrestrial surface and harvest plants
or examine plants or possibly make it my
home
i'm guaranteed to sink about
40 hours in the first day you might say
adrian it's only 24 hours in the day not
when you play games like that there's
more than 20 hours in the game like that
and look long ghostbusters said dude the
walking dead season one had me crying so
hard at the end i feel you
i feel you
that's why i don't play those games
anymore because i don't have time to be
that emotional all the time
but if i need a way to do it then i'll
play those games whole bunch of games
coming to game pass obviously great
things to look forward to and we're only
seven minutes deep in this cast right
how exciting is that
and the best part is is that even though
we have all this happening
we have people here to speak about games
as well so it's not just me rambling
away we are going to talk about little
game called call of the wild the angler
and i'll be joined by our first guest
rushy okay now here's something i need
you to understand about this
the angler is an open world fishing game
and it's designed for players right to
explore the vast and very beauty of
nature right because we love that i'm
talking about riding the open waters and
teaming up with friends and enjoying a
truly immersive fishing experience
because who doesn't love doing that
through all your games right
before we say hello by the way to russia
why not just show you a little gameplay
montage right a trailer take a look
[Music]
magnificent ain't it
there's something about this place
that makes all your problems seem
well
small i guess
out here you're free at last
roman wherever you like day or night
from high mountain lakes to
gorgeous valleys
on your own or with your favorite
fishing buddies you'll make memories for
life
but if you're gonna take home more than
a story of the one that got away
you're gonna need your wits about you
official spook if you don't approach
them right
and you'll need to use the right gear at
the right time in the right place
lucky for you the locals around here are
as good as they come
and ready to lend a hand if you need it
so
what do you
let's go fishing
call of the wild
the
[Music]
angler that is called the wild angler
and i'm joined with rushy right now game
director welcome aboard id at xbox how
are you
oh thank you so much i'm feeling good
thanks
nice it's good to see you're already in
the great outdoors you're obviously
gonna do a live gameplay demo or
discussion right there in the heart of
where the fishing takes place how you
doing out there is it comfy and cozy
oh yes the best place to be right in
outdoors soaking in the atmosphere and
the beauty of nature
yeah wonderful
so
as you're looking into a game like this
right
i have friends who love fishing and they
love playing fishing type games they
love getting caught up in fishing and
games aren't even about fishing so
how did this all come together the idea
of saying you know what we should do is
make a fishing game
well as you may know we already make the
hunter all the wild and
one of the biggest community requests
was like we have hunting what would
complement that perfectly and obviously
fishing and were were great at making
massive spectacular outdoor worlds and
it just seemed like the perfect
complementary game to sit alongside the
hunter and we wanted to bring something
unique to fishing as well because you
know the there aren't ever fishing is
where you can explore open worlds and
try and find that fish fishing spots we
feel like we brought something new to
the genre as well
that is actually new because i'm used to
being so pedestrian right where i just
go to a fishing spot and i park there
and i'm there for the next let's call it
three hours real time or in game time
doesn't matter right you're sitting in
this one location but you're teasing the
idea of get up and go this open world
style so
how do you populate a game like that
where it's just not a patch of grass
here and then suddenly uh a waterbed
division
yeah that's been one of the biggest
challenges was trying to work out how do
we actually build a systemic system that
populates this massive open world with a
variety of fish species so we had to
create a system which simulates a lot of
the elements of the depth of water the
turbidity of water temperature etc all
these crazy stats and things that then
decide where the fish are placed and
when they spawn at relative to the time
of day uh to make sure it's a you know
realistic fishing adventure where you
need to go out pick your spot and use
the right gear to find the fish that
you're after
now
i'm happy you're answering the important
questions because we got another one
right here in chat from md14 saying can
we pet the fish
oh man i don't know that sounds like a
great emote or something to add down the
line
[Laughter]
i like that idea and you were speaking
just a second ago about how much it
matters for the time of day for a fish
so when you say things like that is
there the inclusion of a day night noon
kind of system of knowing when to fish
yeah so we've got like a full dynamic 24
hour um day to night cycle so if you're
fishing
yeah it makes a difference not just in
terms of like visibility of course you
know when you're wondering about the the
wild in the dark but also the
temperatures of water and activities of
the fish some fish are more active at
night so again if you go to certain
locations you're going to get a better
chance to try and catch one of our
bigger diamond fish
that is the most appealing thing i can
think of because it's easy to get lost
like it's just so cool to play fish and
games where it's just always daytime but
the idea of having a day night cycle and
the depth of water matters and i saw in
the trailer too i thought i saw like
tide pools and one like crevasse of a
mountain side right there so
how are you going to navigate all that
terrain do we just get out and walk and
run or how's that
operate i mean if you like this little
pace you can walk if you want to but
obviously you know this is i think 24 by
24 square kilometers so what's that in
my 20 20 miles squared let's say so we
wanted to make sure you can actually
navigate the waterways on boats of
course you can go up and down our lakes
and rivers and fish from them of course
but we've also added like a 4x4 vehicle
so if you want to go over some of the
bumpier terrain or you get from lake to
lake you can jump in one of them not
just alone get a few friends in jump in
the jeep jump on a boat and go on a
fishing adventure together
you are speaking my language and plus i
love the idea i've played many games
where you can kind of get inside the
vehicle and drive around and i love
being the driver so i look forward to
someone saying we're gonna fish over
there and saying no we're gonna fish
over there instead because i'm in charge
of the vehicle and we actually have i
think some live gameplay footage right
now we can take a look at so that way we
have a little bit of a ingenuity going
on and right there uh look at that
classy pax is playing the angler right
now and looks like this looks like a
better way rushy to travel than just on
foot or by jeep right the
fastest one of the fastest ways one of
the most direct ways it looks like it's
heading towards the old sawmill over
there so we've got like a really good
variety of like points of interest and
locations that make the world worth
exploring
um but around here i know there's quite
a few rainbow trout around this area so
let's see what he's oh he's picking his
right rod getting the correct setup for
what he's after he's got some really
good rigs there already he looks like
he's been playing it quite a bit because
of course you can you can buy new gear
personalize your your gear it's that
just try and you know target specific
you know fish species
i feel like we're doing a professional
broadcast of like an actual pro fishing
debut you're like ah yes plenty of
rainbow trout over there for sure i'm
just kind of nodding like yeah i
you're right there are plenty over there
there's another question from chat too
from axion 2 saying how many fish
species are in the game you can delve on
that i think which was the best one yes
at the moment we've got one open world
called golden ridge reserve and in that
we've got 12 different fish species so i
think you can see them right there so
you've got the likes of rainbow trout
mighty mountain whitefish northern pike
yellow perch uh channel catfish bluegill
uh smallmouth bass last night basics i
could list them all off and of course
you know
as you've probably seen with um the
hunts and what we've done in the past
we've always expanded upon you know
what's included in that there's a day
one release so hopefully you'll see a
lot more down the line as well
do you see a lot more of this happening
in the future too we can just kind of
walk out there in the wilderness
[Laughter]
like this before
[Laughter]
he's admiring he's admiring the
landscape
you need to do that i mean this is a
great way to get your instagram feed
bumped up it's by doing moments like
this so i respect it uh curtis posada
chat says can you cook the fish
it's a really good game
we operate a very ethical form of
fishing here so it's a catch and release
you know we want to make sure those fish
go back into the water
and we want to look after our friends
so
you know i wonder about this right
because when when classy pax right there
was going through the listings of the
different rotten types right that there
are people who will do fishing as a way
to just kind of pass time by they're not
really sure what lures to use or what
line to use or even what the edge of the
dock is actually called and then there
are people who do this for a living or
had someone teach them how do you strike
that balance between welcome to our game
i know nothing and welcome to our game
if you know everything
yeah that's always a really tough
balance to try and find you know making
sure that those who fish in real life
can just jump in unimpeded and play
versus those who are new to fishing
because we wanted to appeal to a wider
audience and as you mentioned at the
beginning there are lots of games out
there which don't focus on fishing but
have fishing on the side and we wanted
to kind of bring those type of people in
as well so we've got that first-time
user experience for the first half an
hour so we will really kind of guide you
through all the basics and teach you a
lot but then we want the social other
things whereby because you're in a
seamless connected world of our players
we wanted to build relationships and um
teach each other you know these are the
best fishing spots so this is the best
bait to use in this circumstance so
hopefully we can build a community of
anglers who you know who will help each
other out
i love the way you say that too
hopefully we can build a community of
anglers i just like that the future
tense and the confidence in it too and
you're not the only one with confidence
apparently because philosophy said
mark my words i will catch the
largest pass and for someone like me for
things like that i have to wonder is is
there a photo mode or just press the
screenshot button or how are we
capturing this
yeah so as soon as you've caught that
fish and you you hold it in your hands
you can press one of the buttons to hide
all the hood and then snap your picture
to get you know to capture that magical
moment of the biggest catch because
obviously one of the best things is you
know catching a 30 pound bass uh diamond
ranked you know and being able to shut
it off to your friends right
yeah it is that's really cool if you
have a way to get rid of the ui and shut
off your friends and say beat that i
like that
so obviously people in the chat right
now are interested in this so where can
chat follow up on updates on call the
wild the angler
um well you can get more updates from uh
call the wild angler at cltw
theangler.com uh of course you can
follow us on twitter at
see again cstw the angler
and
if you want jump into our discord as
well
nice thank you for your time russia it
was an amazing experience you really
brought the knowledge forth and i could
almost smell the pine scent behind you
in your background so all of this was
very enjoyable
thank you for bringing yourself here
thank you very much it was a pleasure
and everyone else hey if you like the
gameplay that you saw just now uh it
turns out we're gonna watch some more of
classy pax
doing more of the uh maybe he'll walk on
water i don't know but the best way to
tune in is watching here right now watch
classy packs play some more of call the
wild the angler and then we'll come back
with more stuff right here at idiot xbox
fall showcase stay tuned
good stuff
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
it's only a bronze but i don't care it
is my bronze
i will accept it
look at that beaut
it's gorgeous
we're gonna go a little more over deep
into that pocket and we're gonna get
another one
there's a big one in there i can smell
it i can smell it i say
it's actually one there's a big one
right there
look at it we'll get it
watch
watch learn
oh it's still tasty
i still haven't even gone
i still haven't even cooked a fish yet
actually for the past
month
i've been meaning to do like a battered
fish
oh
so what's the best reel in your opinion
i have a hard time with the bait casters
oh the bait casters
you mean the match rods keep the match
rods
are you talking about
with the bobber
casting out actual bait
yeah match rods and combi with bait
casters
ah gotcha it don't really matter too
much depending on what you're going for
you just need to make sure that
the way it works is you want a rod that
could take the poundage you're looking
at then a reel that can match that
poundage and then the line to go with it
and then certain lines will
be stronger or harder to see
for the fish like i'm using the
terminology they use for a flora film
monoform so it's hard for the fish to
see but braided
high visibility yeah braids the best
braided lines the best for strength
or strength
but a lot of fish will avoid it because
you can see it
so there's a trade-off right but
if you want to catch a diamond lake
trout
lean on that braided get the braided
line
otherwise
you're gonna struggle
cause it's gonna snap
hey welcome back to id at xbox i'm your
host okay adrian we just got done doing
some pretty fun stuff so if you weren't
here you missed out on a little bit we
had an interview with rushy about call
the wild the angler so if you happen to
love fishing you were here right on time
if you weren't don't worry you can
always watch it back later or maybe you
can clip it and share with the friend
and do that also make sure this entire
time that you're chatting along your
comments could be featured look look
right down there this is live happening
right now that is demetrius the bean
lord saying hello and there's pyrrhic
saying i'm really excited to get my
group of nerds out in the water i'm sure
that's going to be hilarious uh you're
probably right right
something else that might be hilarious
or enjoyable with friends or alone is
our next game because wouldn't you know
what we have more games right here on id
at xbox
we're going to have an interview right
with nicholas and gabriel the devs of
the game
born of bread
not a typhoon that's a really cool name
for a game now the kind of game it is
it's an rpg where you play as a flower
golem who possesses the never-ending
child like wonder and a set of
audibilities you're going to team up
with a colorful cast of characters
explore different regions of a wonderful
world ripe with mysteries and engage in
a fun and quirky turn-based combat
system
that's a lot of words might be easier
just to take a look so let's do that
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
i
love it immediately born of bread just
like me and we're joined right now by
nicholas and gabriel of wild arts
welcome to both of you if you would take
a moment to please introduce yourselves
one at a time and what it is you do
okay okay uh my name is gabriel i'm the
art director on the born of bread
and i'm nicholas i'm the lead programmer
and designer on board of brit
lead programmer art director welcome to
both you happy you had time to be with
us let's just get into it right away
because everyone in chad is saying the
same thing that i thought of right away
which is
it looks like a little game called
i don't think i say it p.m the initials
pm let's call it that right it looks a
lot like pm
is that on purpose yes
yeah absolutely it's one of our biggest
inspiration for sure yeah
yeah we're big fans
okay big fans of that game right so
obviously anytime you create a game you
want to go your own way right even
though you have an inspiration behind it
so
as you take cues from
pm along the way right what are the
things you're looking to do in this game
to set it apart from games like that
okay well uh there's a couple of things
um
so while we take inspiration from it we
don't like aim to make a spiritual
successor so we take some liberties at
some points
but we really try to
keep in mind the core aspects that made
the early games really special for a lot
of people
so for instance we kept the linear story
uh which takes you through uh five
distinct regions which are like themed
worlds
and uh each of these worlds have their
own set of characters and unique locals
to meet some of them as side quests and
things like that
and throughout those regions you'll also
be able to meet
characters that will accompany you
through the rest of the game yep
i love that answer and my eyes lit up as
soon as you said side quests right a
linear game but also hey here are like
five little icons saying you can do this
if you want to you don't have to but the
option is there and i love that kind of
stuff and if we're thinking about you
know paper mario we'll say the name if
we're thinking about a game like that
are we gonna find ourselves having to
get like i don't know a pen to paper to
track things like heading blocks left
right middle if you know what i'm saying
yeah uh well first off before answering
your question i just want to put a
little disclaimer that what you're
seeing right now is uh footage from a
demo we released last year
okay so it's a bit rough around the
edges and a lot of things may have
changed but it still represents pretty
well the core aspects yeah wait till you
see the game
yeah yeah
so
we don't have to worry about any like
story spoilers or things like that it's
really like self-contained
okay uh so yeah to answer your question
uh
about the sitequest we decided not to go
with quest boards uh instead
uh what you'll do is uh when you meet an
npc and talk to them some may have side
quests available
and when they do
uh it'll be added to your journal which
is like your your in-game menu
and you have like multiple ones active
at once and we really try to make it
like feel organic like you just you talk
to these people and
you decide to help them or not yeah and
all the heavy lifting for like tracking
and stuff that's done on my end you
don't have to keep track on pen and
paper yeah it'll be pretty clear what
you have to do at all times
you are you are an a1 programmer thank
you so much for keeping that in mind
it means a great deal right uh
when you're looking at a game like this
do you
you have your little log right there
right your little registers so you can
use that to keep track of everything
will be some backtracking as well so if
i end up in biome 2 well i find myself
going back to biome one
yeah well actually that's all the fun
things in the game um there's some uh
like we said everybody that you meet has
his own special ability and that can be
used to uh do different things for
instance like the raccoon character uh
that we showcase right now his name is
lind and he can dig up mounds of dirt
and he can open paths you can find
treasure in the ground and that's really
cool for uh also backtracking because uh
when you have access to a certain region
you can go back and then do all the
stuff that you missed out on with the
new buddy that you're acquired and
that's really great uh we have some
shortcuts that
are super weird sometimes like there's a
one in a forest that's just like an old
subway that reaches into uh the city
area and it's really fun like to just
walk around and discover the the the
shortcuts yeah and the point i want to
add to that is that you know while we
stick to like a linear story uh we
wanted to allow ex like exploration and
optional stuff you can do between story
beats so
you could find like a secret bath to a
whole level that doesn't isn't
necessarily or
has lots of like neat stuff hidden in it
and treasure yeah treasure
i love the excitement in that treasure
you're speaking my language for that
kind of intensity i love it what is this
is that one of the abilities to turn
flat and make yourself a parasol
well
well of course there's the abilities for
the buddies and loaf can also do certain
things since he's a flower golem he's
he's really like squishy and that allows
him to be crushed really easily uh
there's loads of abilities like that
like the one where he gets picked up
with the butterflies we showcased
earlier uh there's lots of other ones
but we don't want to spoil it too much
yeah sure of course
that makes sense i don't know if you can
answer this portion but at one point the
the last gameplay video we saw
uh our friend loaf right here with the
little ladle smacking away and there was
a chat in the upper right hand corner
are you able to tell us about that
yeah of course uh i'll go ahead um the
that's the battle broadcast it's
basically like a twitch stream that we
have
uh but it's all in game of course uh and
like a real chat uh the chat reacts to
your successes and your blunders so if
you perform poorly they'll let you know
yeah and if you perform well they'll
give you some advantages in battle
so yeah really oh you get crowd bonuses
if you perform well
yeah it's like a arctic on the paper
mario's crawl system you try to like
modernize it and add a few things that i
think
players will really enjoy
yeah sometimes they just think of the
weirdest stuff
yeah no that's yeah so it's really weird
and cool they're angry
mcducky potatoes says super excited to
play this game and honestly i i believe
it look loaf looks so lovable and rose
7803 says omg that's neat kitty cat face
so people are already pumped for this i
feel like
as low
with the idea of what they are and this
battle system i feel like we're like one
secret item away or like one second
pinch away from turning into like a
super bread like a flax seed
it's like a super power later on is
there an evolutionary period at all or a
way to buff up with items and things
like that
yeah there's loads of stuff to talk
about there's the weapons you can find
there's this thing that we're we're
calling boons uh this is basically our
take on the uh badges from paper mario
uh they allow you to they can range from
like staff upgrades to new mechanics the
in combat and it can really like make
you
change your build so that like my my
loaf or my team is completely different
from gabriel's team like mine is
obviously the glass cannon i i like like
stacking damage and just ignoring
completely my agents just to do as much
as i can and he's probably more of a
defensive guy
uh i'll rother i'll round it
around who's very safe other than you
know who's who's gonna ko at first me or
you so that's a good way to do it and
gabriel we have a quick moment for that
too the time that we have left when
you're designing a game like this and
creating art direction
uh
things that are happening in the
background i feel like for especially
two and a half d style games there's
always things happening in the
foreground in the background that you
can either head to or not go to
how much of that is happening in this
game as far as stuff happening in the
background
so
while we
were 2.5 d we try to make it feel like a
3d game
so there's a lot of levels that have
like a depth to them uh
and um
it's
it's a hard question uh
but i think the main thing
is to make sure that everywhere you go
it's interesting to see and there's
details to see
especially some areas that are maybe a
more a bit more lore heavy uh
we're trying to put a lot of cool stuff
to find and
secrets that can
reveal a bit more of the the lore behind
the of the story and things like that
yeah and from a level design standpoint
the z-axis in a 2.5 d game is really
powerful it allows you to like guide the
player really easily so we have work
usually like the objective sometimes
it's in the background and you can
really help the player find their way uh
using like the medium
well you navigated that question very
well without giving anything away so i'm
proud of both of you waiting up off the
trap where can chad follow updates on
board of bread
uh our main uh
our twitter handle
it'll be on twitter so uh at
waldartsdevs that's where we share all
the all the cool info
oh perfect well thank you both for
joining us and giving us details in this
gym it looks outstanding and a lot of
people right now in the twitch chat are
looking super pumped to play it so thank
you for your time
thank you thank it's been great
yeah
look at that
wasn't that neat yet we've already had a
fishing game and now we have a game like
you know that other game right so id and
xbox is popping right now
with cool titles whether through trailer
or game plays and things like that uh
turns out we're not done doing that
there's going to be more gameplay coming
up and guess what features oh my god it
features me
i'll be playing video games i get a
chance to put my hands on brand new
games i'll be doing it live in front of
all of you
so this next game by the way is going to
be really fun okay
spider heck
i'm not cleaning that up either that's
the actual title it's called spider heck
and it's a non-stop co-op brawler where
you step into the mini shoes of an elite
spider soldier okay capable of slashing
and blowing enemies to bits and they're
from the devs of never jamming
publishers tiny build
let's go ahead and take a look at the
trailer and then i'll jump in to play
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone guess what i'm back it's
the id xbox fall showcase i'm your host
okay adrian and not only now am i your
host i'm also your gameplay demo er or
enthusiast this is spider heck alright
now this is me i'm actually controlling
it how do you have proof because look
here's my controller right here all
right that's me moving left that's me
moving right this isn't one of those
demos we're pretending like we play it
at the same time and this is not a live
gameplay so i hope i get good really
quickly all right
so let's take a look around at what's
happening there's the title spider heck
shout outs to that
hold any button to join okay
and right here is a little weapon i'm
gonna pick that up oh
oh and this
it's a rave party
i don't really know if i would use this
as a weapon maybe if i'm like
crime scene investigator
uh there's versus battle need at least
two players needed for that okay
i don't even know one other person so
that doesn't help me
wave survival a high score of three
oh i have to stay stationary on it and
then i can actually go into the wave
survival all right
uh velociflu says i'm planning to go pro
and spider heck well if you do you gotta
go through me
because high score three uh beatable
and big l69 was that a reference it was
all right gameplay time
i hope i'm good
okay what we got here
okay
easy
video games
all right so i have a weapon down there
is some mine i don't know if it's timed
or
okay
there's my opposition it looks like
it looks like a movie theater uh
ushering excuse me spider uh
may i see your id for this movie
look at it's actually a movie theater
usher with a little flashlight and
everything then get out of here all
right
i bought this ticket online
uh i don't want that any longer
oh
perfection why thank you very much wow
wow
okay it looks like there's different
effects that take place for a map
blade master particle blade ex
impacts slow down time oh each one of
these not only changes the parameter of
the game but it also changes the map it
looks like too slow some cove
particle technology particle blades
cause more knockback balance oh that's
uh that's fd all right
objectification your web can attach to
enemies on cargo
i don't mind slowing down time let's go
blademaster
yeah modifiers
are we winning i don't know yet i hope
so
okay
i feel that looks like death
there's one thing i've learned from
video games it's
literally what just happened
i feel like there's some kind of lesson
to be learned there but uh i don't know
it
i just want to get down to that gun okay
oh fast
no no no no
why do you get a gun
no no no don't shoot don't shoot don't
shoot
why would you throw the gun adrian
okay i don't want it that badly
listen i'm sorry
okay no one's watching this happen right
so no one just saw that take place i
feel like i'm safe i'm still a
gamer you like that make you nervous me
too
okay so the goal obviously was to beat a
high score of three i did that uh
we need not talk about the results
otherwise we're gonna hop back into it
all right
so very cool
the web slinging is quite adorable
i don't even know what happened to me
right there i saw the movie theater
usher walk up i had my ticket stub out
and i still got blasted
i'm gonna stand right here
and just wait for my position right this
is how i play video games anyway it's
just
is that a chariot
oh it's like made of blades
oh no
no
i'm so sad right now so it looks like
it's not just this way to play right
there's different ways to play uh
there's pvp pve co-op as i said earlier
uh i don't know how co-op works because
that would require a friend
leave me alone
please spawn
okay
i'm terrified never mind
[Laughter]
i'm so happy now
so apparently this arenas are randomly
generated too so
uh i guess i can kind of prep for it i
was going for a double shot
oh
why is my life
who
who was that
i was like the jason bourne of
antagonist
i want to say that i had a chance to do
better there uh i didn't
and i'm going to get better chat i
promise you
i just got ushered out of the game you
watch your mouth alright are you right
yes did it hurt my feelings no because
guess what
video games
it means you can have a new level yeah
that's true i guess right
i love the different upgrades they have
to the different ways you can fight i'm
sure that playing this another person
like pvp style would be a blast right
trying to figure out what way to move
paying people to go the wrong direction
things like that
i also wonder like
not to get so close to anything they
explode but i also wonder later on too
how dynamic it's going to be when the
levels get harder right because we're on
wave 2 right now and i imagine like at
wave
50 i cannot believe it's coming back
this way
uh
okay
i'm just gonna stand here and do this
you will now grant me the title of
master all right
oh don't spawn there
okay nice
chat you're empowering me right now
you're making me do better i also like
the fact that there's different weapons
right the lightsaber the grenade
launcher
and look at this uh stronger web pull
yeah give me that
power web it is
yeah matching the movement conkey talks
looks like it's going to be very
difficult
right because right now i'm having
why is the ceiling lava
that's literally against the rules
remember when you were a kid and you hop
around the furniture your living room
and play the game called the floor is
lava you hop from like couch to kitchen
counter
it was never the ceiling as lava and
that's why because this is tumultuous
i missed
you
missed i'm so scared right now
the knock back of the gun i'm so mad
all right it's okay we're better we're
smarter we're stronger
oh my god how do you miss
why is this game doing this to me
okay never mind i'm good at games
i'm bad at games
you're still alive
oh it's the thing from resident evil in
the movie
okay
i've just been told by production that
i haven't earned the right to play more
video games because i was so bad at it
they didn't tell me that that's my own
self-loathing that was a lot of fun
yeah that game is called spider heck so
obviously we're looking forward to that
as soon as that happens you can download
the game for free on steam it turns out
between september 22nd and 26th
so obviously that's pretty cool
i'm gonna go ahead and disconnect in
this game too and a surprise we are
dropping game codes in chat right now
they're first come first sub so make
sure you grab them right away okay you
can go ahead and redeem those codes on
steam and find more information about
that game on steam spider hack and go to
spiderheck.com
that was fun enough for me being bad at
games we have more game trailers so take
a look
long have i
waited i name you chain breaker
child of the world of the pulp
you must do what i cannot do
my people
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hi i'm patrick makavina
one of the developers at moving pieces
i'm here to share with you some new game
play for a title shoulders of giants
shoulders of giants is an explosive
sci-fi roguelike where you
simultaneously control germ a sore
wielding robot and froggy a gunslinging
space frog on a quest to rescue the
galaxy from the forces of entropy
each mission and shoulders of giants
takes place on a randomly generated
landscape it combines the best of
handcrafted level design with procedural
generation
combat challenges you to mix your
gameplay between froggy's range powers
and germ's melee focus tool set swapping
back and forth to pull off powerful
combos
the fun of shoulders of giants lives in
finding clever and satisfying ways to
play with your ever-changing box of toys
in these 3d alien playgrounds
as you fight back the corrupting forces
of entropy you'll restore these dying
planets to their former glory
watching worlds transform from dark and
barren to full of life in real time
after each mission you'll visit the hub
world
the last bastion of light in the
universe where these scrappy space
survivors call home
these animal allies will provide you
with missions outfits weapons
and skill tree upgrades to further hone
froggy and germs power
finally shoulders of giants has been
designed from the ground up to be an
awesome experience to share with your
friends
online co-op games can be played with up
to four players each controlling their
own frog and robot duo
or if you really want to work out your
relationship skills you can play in our
unique best friend mode where one player
controls the frog and the other player
controls the robot for total co-op
making
shoulders of giants is coming out on
xbox one and xbox series consoles later
this year and we can't wait for you to
play it
if you want to see more head to
playsog.com to learn out how to sign up
for our closed beta with signups open
right now thanks for watching and
remember
shoulders of giants is the only video
game with the frog in it
[Music]
i tell you it takes a lot of rage to
stare across eight realms of hell
an ocean of knees into the eyes of the
red judge and still think
i'm coming for you
[Applause]
[Music]
her guns were the drums of hell
me
i'm just a fan i'm still here
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
this devastation feels like
[Applause]
[Music]
really hoping we don't get democrat for
that
really hoping that hey a lot of cool
games on display right there though
right little things for everyone song of
iron 2
obviously looks dope shoulder of giants
i'm excited for the best friend mode one
person controlling froggy one person
controlling germ that'll be an explosive
experience and of course top it out on
metal hellsinger which someone in the
chat got super excited for it was
yorkshire bother who was
really really happy about that so i'm
happy for you and it turns out metal
hill singer is going to be available on
september 15th on game pass so make sure
to check that out
and oh look at that rocky hot metal
hello rising is probably the most
probably the game i'm most hyped to play
this year
uh yes metal hellsinger is going to be
amazing right and you want to see more
of it i'm sure you do that's why we
actually have someone playing it right
now so what's gonna happen is we're
gonna take a quick break okay i'm gonna
get some more water and parched but in
the meantime you can watch someone whose
name by the way is crusader which is
appropriate you can watch crusader play
some more metal hell singer so stay
tuned and also check this out id xbox
false
showcase ritual had succeeded
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
keep up the 60 multiplier
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
out of my way
[Applause]
i hate this part
wow
hello spring killer
[Music]
uncut
hell knew they had a problem what with
us being this far into their end zone
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to id xbox the
fall showcase that was metal hell singer
and it was a good time right obviously
crusader was doing a wonderful job
better than i think what i could do uh
yeah is there a rate happening there's a
hashtag spider heck happening welcome in
everyone and welcome to the show
as it turns out we have a lot more stuff
happening today we've already seen
things about fishing tons of indie games
more interviews gameplay demos and along
the way i want to make sure to remind
all of you you can co-stream this event
so if you're not doing that already go
ahead and grab your chat watch it
together code stream it together and the
most important part about this entire
experience is all of you watching right
now so all of your comments like all of
you commenting right now spider heck can
come in here commentate and chat and we
may feature you right down below
add to that live experience another way
to add to that live experience is by
doing interviews with dabs that you can
post questions too as i'm asking them
questions too
questions to questions too
up next we have another game and more
guests we have stefan and alexandru
they're the devs of moon stars and
that's an action-adventure fighting game
that pushes the limits of your combat
skills where you master new abilities to
progress through an unforgiving
non-linear 2d world you'll face off
against relentless darkness that seeks
to destroy
you
now in moon scars every death is a
lesson learnt and as you overcome each
challenge new truths will be revealed
a lot of good stuff to listen to let's
watch it too trailer time
[Music]
lesser beings could never bear
the most hunger
drives you
as you search for your creator
but
well here i am precious one right here
what would you ask of me
that was the moon scars trailer looks
outstanding and we're joined by stefan
alexandria to give us more details on
that right here at id xbox stefan
alexandru thank you for joining us how
are you both doing today
thanks i'm doing great
thank you for having us
for sure appreciate you being here now
it says down below stefan you are art
director and alexander lee programmer
hey we have the same match up earlier
this would be great you can answer all
the questions possible for this game and
if you haven't seen already chat is
already super excited for this thing
things like i'm getting castlevania
vibes or i love the look of this game i
dig the art style so stefan you gotta
have a little feather in your cap
reading things about that when it comes
to art so how'd you go with this art
direction what inspired you
uh
yeah thank you i guess uh
sharing a passion for traditional art
i'm a big fan of like i like to oil
paint and
that
we took that into our art style into
pixel art so the result looks like
something that many people call like
a oil painterly pixel art
but it also was uh it came from our
limitations since we're a very small
team we only have uh like for the most
part we were only one or two artists on
the game
so we didn't have much time to go into
very
many details and so yeah it came from a
limitation but the people seem to
enjoy it
yeah they really do i mean one or two
people that's that's the heart of india
right there right and it's already being
appreciated so you should be very proud
of yourself it must be nice too to take
something you already enjoy oil painting
and bringing to life in a game and
speaking of bringing things to life
alexandria as we look in a game like
this this almost metroidvania style game
there's a lot of different ways you can
build games like this and you're always
looking to bring something new
what is it that you had a vision of in
this game
uh yes we aimed to make what we all love
in this genre so a high risk reward
game that you
um
sorry i had this kind of word game
but we uh
unlike most of
the well-known games of this genre we
also wanted to have
a very fast based combat because we
thought that's what best sticks with 2d
and
i i will say one thing though
i want you to finish your thought at the
same time i'm looking on the screen and
everyone else is going to point this out
too i see a cat all right
and as a cat owner this is very
important stephan i saw your reaction
all right this is very important cats
are super important we gotta know right
away
what is the interaction with the cat and
of course can you pet the cat
about letting uh if you can pet the cat
i guess the bigger question is if the
cat will let you too but
the way how you can interact basically
uh it tells you a lot of bits of stories
it helps you along your way
in your quest and
if you
find the
the items that he is looking for then he
will you can exchange it with them with
him uh
for uh for different
helpful things for you so
yeah
the cat actually
is a companion for for the most part of
the game so uh not really a companion
but a a character that uh appears a lot
so
you are 100 describing an actual cat
they're kind of a companion well i mean
like a roommate they'll help you if you
give them stuff i don't know they might
not that's par for course that's exactly
how cats operate
now uh looking in a game like this i got
to know what
what happened what are we what are we
dealing with right here why who are we
yes um so we play escray irma she is a
glay statue clay statue that was brought
to life by our main antagonist the
sculptor
and the sculptor some time ago made the
army for the king
of these clay statues
they were made in the image of men of
the real people and so they shared their
traits their thoughts their personality
and at some point
these clay statues took their mind of
their own so they
they divert the path of what humanity
wanted to want these claibornes wanted
so
yeah they turned against their own
creators so great irma has a pivotal
role in this quest to discover how that
came to be what happened
and what happened to her comrades and to
seek a global solution to end this
conflict
that about lines up giving that a boss
right here has the name traitor to
describe them so that all lines up
properly uh yorkshire bothers said
what's it like in terms of difficulty is
it a hollow knight-esque experience what
are we talking about here
um i think it's pretty difficult
obviously it was where souls fans and it
was it was inspired by souls fans but uh
also we hope it will uh have its uh
it will offer a unique experience in its
own way
so i wouldn't like i don't want to
categorize it like if it's more
difficult than whole light or not i
guess it's pretty different so
it's better to leave it to be found out
no i mean that actually makes a lot of
sense because that earlier prompt one of
the things it says is that in moon scars
every death is a lesson learned no one
puts that in a game unless you are going
to encounter a lot of deaths right
you're not gonna just play a regular
game and say oh you know what if you die
you die maybe you learn nothing i don't
know so this game is meant to teach you
along the way
as you progress through it and someone
else pointed out uh gekko 12 that the
animation flows so nicely how important
was it to you to make sure the game
flowed as well as it looked
thank you well obviously in an action
game the animation is probably
one of the most important parts so we
really put a lot of care and
time into it to make it as responsive
and smooth as possible
and uh i think we
actually achieved it so
yeah it was very important for
to answer the question it shows honestly
i just saw a really cool ricochet attack
takes place and also on the far wall on
the far right hand side i saw what
looked like to be like a hidden room
like they were fighting an enemy the
enemy got knocked back into the air
through a wall they progressed right and
there was a room that was not
highlighted which gives me feels about
metroidvania games can we expect a lot
of that
yes yeah and the best traditions
yeah in the best tradition of the genre
we obviously are going to have a lot of
secrets and hidden rooms to discover
many interesting items
so yeah that was a hidden room
yeah also it's a part of the quest that
we make for the characters that we
encounter we'll also
if we decide to help them that's not
always a sure decision uh we also will
have to travel different parts of the
world and search for
what we need in order to help them
and evolve the story i'll
discover new things about what happened
no i i love that i love the fact that as
you go through a game there's always a
decision of i feel like in games
whenever you help someone the idea is
i'm doing the right thing this is for
the greater good
but i love the idea of hey maybe you
help someone out and maybe it wasn't the
right decision and i feel like a lot of
souls games are very much like that do
you help this person because you feel
like it's going to benefit you in some
way or maybe is it better just to say
nah i don't want to do that
axion 2 says can you change weapons or
is it only the two-handed sword
the two-handed sword is the main weapon
that we fight most of the way but we
also have a selection of additional
weapons that we can experiment with well
obviously on top of that we have a
a nice
set of spells that we can use
and
like stones that provide us passive
bonuses and we can mix them up to make
our own style somebody prefers to play
the defensive style somebody like me
play likes to play aggressive and take
risks but have more rewards
so
yep we can
change weapons
that's actually perfect to hear in
alexandria i'm really happy to hear that
you play just like me
reckless give me all the offense if i
don't block i guess that's on me i hope
it works out the fact you can have some
kind of system of boons to help you out
through that sounds really really cool
uh hexagon with several x's and g's ask
are levels linear
no they are not
linear
it's uh
i guess you could say it's an open world
game and uh okay
po will help to exploit yourself
sometimes do a little backtracking so
not so much uh we
let the option to travel through the
world from the early game you can
teleport
almost right away so yeah the the world
is non-linear
[Music]
teleporting right away is huge i love
exploring big games but man sometimes
when you have to traverse long
landscapes and there's no way to get
from point a to point g
uh that can hamper an experience uh
figure there's probably a lot of balance
when it calls for that also people want
to know how long is the game going to be
do you think
it's a tough question that we get asked
quite often
and it's also hard to answer since uh
for both of us for every one of us on in
the team it takes a very different
amount of time so
i think it's better to just wait for
game to release and to see like uh
what's uh
what's the number that we most often
encounter from from the players before
answering that
now that that makes sense i agree with
that it's hard to give a concrete amount
of time and say oh yeah it'll be a cool
40 hours and then i go in and i'm not
blocking i'm not parrying i'm just
running straight ahead and pressing one
button i'm like what it took 80 hours
how'd that happen i understood how it
takes place
corrupt zed says do we have any
equipment or character levels or
customizations
well yes as uh was mentioned before we
have a set of weapons that can choose
from
we can equip amulets that provide
different bonuses some are offensive
some are offensive some are
miscellaneous like allowing us to make
two dashes in a chain for example
and
yes there is character customization in
the functional way usually grey armor
will always stay like we see her now
okay and we also i was actually going to
ask that
kill trade for spells so
oh
yes
yes step on you said the magical phrase
skill tree i i love me a skill tree i
love the idea of hey guess what you have
one point to spin here's a massive tree
so you're talking about things like
being more offensive and being more
defensive i'm guessing the skill tree
plays into that as well the entire way
do you feel like
as you're progressing to the skill tree
may come to a point where you feel like
i'm good or you guaranteed to finish it
i think if you play all the way through
i think uh what we try to achieve is uh
to make every skill every
unlockable spell uh as interesting and
fun to use as possible so hopefully
everyone will be motivated to unlock
everything
if not for the
strong necessity at least to to play it
and see how fun it is and yeah
personally
go ahead i'm sorry
yeah
personally i like to unlock everything
since for me everything is fun to use so
i like to have as many options as
possible
no i totally agree if i see a skill tree
i'm not content with just seeing one
side caught up i want to fill the entire
thing up
everyone who keeps asking what game is
this it is called moon scars and we
gotta ask both of you stefan alexander
first thank you for coming through here
on id and xbox but where can we find
more information about this game should
we choose to
you can find for you can find more info
on our twitter at moonscarsgame and also
we have a very active discord and even
more information
there
so we'll be waiting for you
i like that that's
what we'll be waiting for you so all of
you right now your stefan said he'll be
waiting for you go to the discord check
it all out thank you alexandrine stefan
for joining us thank you for having us
how about that gang moon scars and of
course you can go on the twitter moon
scars game if you want more information
that way so tune in to that
and we've had a lot of games on idx box
ball showcase and that's the tone of
voice i use when it sounds like about to
go away uh we're not we're not going to
stop there's more games to be showed and
to play i mentioned both those words
because we'll be doing both momentarily
because next up we're going to be
chatting with jordan who is one of the
devs of ghostbusters spirit unleashed
and i've seen a few of you in chat today
with ghostbuster related names so guess
what you get to immerse yourself in the
ghostbusters universe as you protect or
haunt multiple unique locations
throughout the game that sounds exciting
right
ghostbusters spirit unleashed is fun
family friendly and allows for all
levels of player ability slime or be
slimed play up to four friends you can
play solo as a new member of
ghostbusters or you can play as a ghost
and guess what there's a trailer check
it out
yeah we saved the world a few times
but between that we provided a needed
service to the masses
that's where you come in we're passing
the torch or better yet
passing the particle drawer giving you
the tools
now let's see if you have the towel
[Applause]
[Music]
working together to watch each other's
back
now i know you're still a ghost-busting
trainee but there's much more here than
meets the eye take a look at this
[Applause]
you have the chance to see firsthand
what exists on the other side
catching ghosts is only the half of it
[Music]
so you want to play as a ghost
i'd like to see you try to take on my
team
everyone welcome back to idx box this is
ghostbuster spirit unleashed i'm joined
by jordan the design director welcome
how you doing jordan
i'm doing great adrian how about
yourself
uh-oh
i don't think i can hear you right
hello
oh there you are hey there is that
coming through cool yeah i said i was
good how about yourself how are you
doing you know what i read your lips and
i thought you said that thank you i'm
feeling perfect
i'm feeling okay i'm a little
intimidated because this game looks
amazing and i feel like you're really
good at it we're playing together and i
just don't want to mess this up man you
know what i mean
trust me i'm not going to be a jerk
about it uh i want to make sure you
experience it and have fun i want to
walk you through it and you know make
sure we have a good time um because yeah
i'm pretty good i'm not gonna brag but
you know i am
uh
i'm excited though this is this is gonna
be good uh this has been something that
we've been working on for a while now
and
it's just been an absolute joy to work
on and there's just so many different
things oh great nice i didn't notice the
cat was so much in frame but i guess
you don't have to don't have to look at
me while i talk but yeah i'm super
excited to be here so thank you for
having me
hey i'll tell you what right now uh
tamika said been waiting for this game
for months looks beyond worth the wait
there's like three different people with
name ghostbusters in chat so it feels
like every showcase there's like three
games people just
the top of the hour they're like hey
what's up when's this and guess what
you're the that and this
that's that's good to hear i mean we've
we've noticed there's a very die hard
fan base behind the ip obviously and to
see everyone popping in and kind of
following along as we slowly drip out a
lot of the content from this game it's
it's awesome to see them react to it at
the same time
has gonna be a blast and i i think you
and i'll be playing together as we
teased earlier so
as we play through this game right away
i have to know how much ghostbusters did
you have to watch
to get this started
i mean so much we've we've been known
for working with a lot of these
different ips in the in the games that
we make and it's extremely important to
look back at the source content material
and ghostbusters is just as true as any
of those and to be able to to you know
not only recognize this as something
that pretty much everyone that's worked
at the studio has grown up with
kind of in different sections too
because you got fans of the original you
got fans of ghostbusters 2.
the animated series there's just so much
content there and that was a big part of
any time we're starting to build
something like this is we go back we
look at all the my new details
throughout all the all the different
pieces of media that exist and try and
make sure we translate that into the
gaming experience because what's more
important about a ghostbusters game than
feeling like it's a ghostbusters game
i agree with that i mean you want to
have that feel right away you want to
have like-minded people along the way
who share the same vision and honestly
you aren't the only one lace the bass
says this will finally let me constantly
reference ghostbusters lines with my
group
so
you know as we're playing through this
too as we tease in the opening there's
the idea of playing as a ghost or a
ghostbuster how does that differentiate
so uh we make we've been making
asymmetrical games um and if you're not
familiar with the term asymmetrical
multiplayer games are where there is uh
one versus many one versus you know two
versus four there's there's an offset in
the team structure and it's it's a fun
way to take it it especially works in
ghostbusters because you have the the
classic ghostbusting crew and then you
have the ghosts which is taking over the
location and it's pretty much building
two different games um we're we're
showing more and more of the ghost game
play as as things come along
and it's an extremely different
experience because you are actively
haunting the building that you're in
you're messing with the ghostbusters
it's a very sneaky very very uh
mischievous role that you take on
whereas of the ghostbusters you're going
in
and it's third person as well so coming
back to the ghostbusters side it's a
first person experience where you were
clearing the building trying to from
this ghost you know you get to use all
the iconic gear and and what better way
to to kind of portray that is from a
first person's perspective where you can
feel that gear operate and feel the
power of it
and when you're going around and busting
these ghosts
i'm so happy you brought that up that's
such a good idea to switch between first
person and third person depending on the
experience you have and you you hit it
right on the head the idea of you want
to see all the colors right you want to
hear all the noises because those are
things that are tied to memory so when
you're in another room if you hear a
certain noise if you watch the franchise
in any portion you know right away what
it is you're listening to right that's
gotta feel really good yeah
and that's that goes into the sound
design that goes in the look we spent a
lot of times looking back on all the
different you know it's it's 80s movies
so like we have to kind of interpret the
vfx that are used luckily after life was
a great reference point more for kind of
what that updated look looks like but
when we're going into the particle
thrower and trying to make sure it's
like hey
when people imagine ghostbusters and
playing in their backyards as kids with
cardboard proton packs like what would
they be imagining actually picking up
that material would feel like in in in
this game
well joke's on you jordan i still do
that as an adult and now i can do that
in the game so
we're playing it right now we're hopping
on in let's take a look at this cool
first off i got to say i love your name
by the way
jordan
great rapper
yeah
yeah you can first i'm first going to
call out that we do have um a big part
of this was we we spent a lot of time in
the character customization realm for
this game we're not going to be really
showing any of that but you can take a
look at our characters right now and
recognize that we've we've spent a lot
of time in making sure that you get to
make yourself or your character give as
many controls as possible to really make
your own ghostbusters because in this
game you're stepping into the shoes of a
ghostbuster or the boots i should say
and and kind of taking on that role to
help out at the firehouse so
that's what's possible i mean you can
see my strong jaw that uh
you know the ghosts are extra scared by
that that kind of problem it looks like
a compass point for the
just fall on my chin
oh my god i just realized that your vest
actually has your name on it
yep
that is so tight i love little editions
like that look at all the glowing stuff
in the blinking light oh my god your
proton pack yep and that's another thing
um
we have is the yeah we have a lot of
customization around the gear as well
because
we while we start as kind of the the
standard stock uh equipment that you see
in every uh in every movie we wanted to
allow you to
mess with gameplay and like start to
choose and find different ways to
upgrade not only visually so the the
equipment starts to turn into something
completely different but also
gameplay-wise there's a lot of minutiae
and like little cool little things that
you can kind of like push for and it's
it's almost like building out your your
character in a way that's like hey this
is the way i like to play this game so
i'm going to equip these different
attachments that allow me to do that
i like that a great deal before we hop
into our first thing is there like a
mirror or
i can take a look at myself and show me
let's uh you'll see it when we start the
match so we have perfect some some
cinematics that'll that'll show your
character
that's funny yeah so
okay let's make sure here we go so we're
going to go out on our first job now i
am going to be the ghost of course so
oh okay of course we'll let you you guys
take care of the of finding me but
like i said i'll take it easy but it's
it's going to be a
it's going to be a fun little experience
here um
production show me his screen
none of that now
[Laughter]
let me ask you you're going ghost right
away but what is your preference what do
you have more fun playing not
necessarily what is more fun but what do
you have more fun playing and why
i
uh let's take a look watch your
character enter majestic
right now with my bret hart sunglasses
on
[Laughter]
i'm gonna find a kid in the front row
and get into him
um but just to quickly answer your
question it's tough i i love both sides
uniquely for different reasons they both
provide such a unique angle on on game
play like he it's it's it's enjoyable
but i mean it depends if if my friends
are in the game i'm totally going after
them as a ghost
uh because it's it's fun to just mess
with
so
first thing i'll call out is yeah you
we've entered the location and now it's
the the job of the busters to find the
the ghosts right so you can pull out
your pke meter
um okay which is going to allow you to
start getting some signals and and
seeing
you just hit uh two i believe all right
unless you're on a controller
i'm a controller right now
um hit uh hit y check this out
oh there we go look at that
so you'll see on the screen so the pke
meters is built pretty faithfully to
the functionality um that we've we've
detected and kind of noticed in a lot of
the now wait a second that that wasn't
moving was it
now
you know
i don't want to point you fingers jordan
but something tells me the soul taking
it easy on me thing i'm looking at this
meter right now oh shoot
the ai does not care
no they don't no they don't they were
not into making sure the showcase goes
well
i like that energy good for them
yeah so i mean that's that's kind of an
oh yeah they're gonna
they're gonna make this
definitely a lot more difficult on me
don't slam me why would you do that
i thought we were friends
sorry i had to get away from that chaos
why would you get away but i dropped you
a few of the the minions that i can use
to distract as well
their traps laid down too they are
really good wow i'm looking around the
game like this is so pretty and they're
like dawg
[Laughter]
no but that's what's great about it is
like we've we've spent a lot of time as
well from our previous experiences in
making these types of games we felt is
extremely important to build out uh the
the ability for these ai to take over
and help you um there's there's a lot of
people that sometimes don't like playing
with other players right so
to be able to give them an opportunity
to just jump in and play regardless if
they have friends to play with or want
to
really play with anyone at
any given time
the ai fill that role and they jump in
and they they're able to competently
move through the match and and do
whatever
a player can't do and look at them
finding me right now this is
okay i'll let you i'll let you get me
just so you can get a get a feel of the
tethering that's happening
i like that i'm going to let you get me
respect
[Music]
you broke the tether why would you do
that
oh look at that little minions that's so
cool
i can clear the slime off of me
that is fantastic
so imagine that oh go ahead
oh no go ahead you go
i was just going to say i imagine as you
progress the game there's going to be so
many different upgrades that you can do
to make this so much easier along the
way for both sides right the different
ways to manipulate people into doing
what you want them to do
yep yeah we have uh we have a bunch of
different ghosts that that will be um
unlockable uh we've shown off a few
you've seen sneak peeks of a few of them
throughout the trailer you saw a few
other ones they'll have
they all play very differently like
we've been building them in ways that
just kind of you know
lean towards different styles of
gameplay there's some that are really
aggressive and
and very quick to respond to to
situations um and then there's some that
are more about being very sneaky so
well jorda gander i had a great time
unfortunately we have like a total of 20
seconds left and i wanted 20 minutes
more
i i lost myself completely the entire
time so i need you to help me out and
let everyone chat know
details about the game where they can
find out more the spotlight is yours
well yeah we are launching on october
18th uh you can check out any news and
updates at
ghostbusters.com or on twitter it's
probably another good place it's a
ghostbusters su as well
so
very excited thank you again for having
me this was a blast yeah thank you so
much jordan thank you for giving me the
podium making me look good too good
looking for humbling
oh of course anything thanks for
stopping in then take care see ya
how cool is that
how fun was that game man i love id at
xbox i hope i made you all proud i want
to play more of that game but hey you
know the good news about video games is
is that when you play one good game you
know you have like three more around the
corner that are just as good and it
turns out we have that and even better
we have trailers for that right
uh how about looking at a brand new set
of games and even one that has surprise
dlc take a look
[Music]
[Music]
you suck at foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you suck at [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how about that right i promised you more
trailers and more goodness and you got
exactly that right first and foremost uh
valheim september 29th coming to game
fast
listen not everyone has the ability to
play on pc and play on xbox is a big
deal and if you can get cross play later
on then you know what's going to be a
good time joe viola is saying pog game
pass valheim i know right hey ron how
are you and you suck at parking by the
way i played that and it is one of the
best games i played this year i'm not
trolling you it is fantastic it's got a
ton of challenges the way you navigate
the cars to park in the parking space is
tons of fun a great pickup and play or
three hour type game and of course
cities skylines dlc right places and
promenades how cool is that 300 brand
new assets couple of things to talk
about really quickly uh number one you
suck at parking is now available in game
pass so hooray we love that right and
available for purchase right now the
city skylines dlc
by the way if you are a game pass
subscriber you will get 10 off of that
and
not to go back to you again joe viola
but you did say and i quote can't wait
to make the city i'm living in and make
it better
i'm sorry i just really love that energy
i hope you have fun playing that on game
pass
if you want to see more of city skylines
and making it a better experience you
can do that right now because we are
going to take you know a quick little
break but in the meantime you can watch
zenkaty playing city skylines dlc
classes and promenades until then stay
tuned id xbox fall showcase
it's so bad everything's fine right it's
fine just tell me everything's fine
please it's fine
oh my goodness
um
can't work like that how do i want this
to go
how do i want this to go
all right i'm gonna delete this
and then i'm going to
do this
and then do that okay
and then we can add um
we'll add our hospitals and stuff like
that
okay
so we'll put a hospital here
so no one gets sick
all those ambulance running on triple
speed right
um okay we'll put a hospital there we'll
go ahead and put
did i i already put a fire station yeah
and i already put police
okay so then on this side
i'll go ahead and put the um
the schools
so we'll do
an elementary school i guess i'll just
put them all together for now and
hopefully that will help this whole
situation
university
okay
so i think all right let's press play
hopefully that will help a little bit
the mayor supports it use oh yeah the
library too smart smart smart yes
library
public library okay yeah and then we'll
put that there
okay let's let's do that
let's do that love a good library of
course you do
of course
okay
so what's going on here so
not enough educated okay i think it's
got a i think it's got a ketchup
it needs to catch up a little bit here
it needs to catch up i am so happy i
moved into a city that
already had all this wow
okay why is everyone sick oh someone
just died
oh no
wait someone just died
oh no
okay
so wait i only have one cemetery does
that oh no
do oh
more people are dying my city is dying
oh and they don't have water oh dear
this is a this is a disaster okay okay
oh
no
okay wait wait wait wait wait so
another cemetery i guess i mean
i'll put that one over there
oh that made them happy that there's a
cemetery
oh wow okay
hey everyone you are tuned in right now
to the idea to xbox fall showcase
wherever you may be watching but i'm
your host right now kadrian and i want
to say thank you so much but no i know
it sounds like we're leaving i should
change the tone of my voice thank you so
much for watching so far right because
the day is not over uh all of you in
chat right now have been talking up a
storm about all your favorite gaming
moments the games you're looking forward
to being kind to each other and florida
poppy
great old school image right there of
the can't be loaded i love that occasion
is the best don't say nice things about
me of everyone you're gonna make me
blush but it's a great showcase i agree
paradox interactive great show tonight
gg thank you
great everything including your games
and run right there a souls master by
the way great speedrunner and a great
co-host
graphics becca singh oh cities
guidelines i love those kinds of games
they're fun right because you can take
an idea of what you think a city or
world should be and you can build that
or you can make it uh worse
or you can make it like something else
you're unfamiliar with or something you
are familiar with there's always
different ways you can play a video game
and the good news is right here you all
been making it very enjoyable and
there's just still more games to play i
know carnage so many id and xbox games
and they're all indie based and i love
me some indie games
someone just call me daddy
oh um our next interview is with
nicholas the game designer at yangling
in ganglet you jump between bubbles that
float in the sky like you're a space
dolphin as you melt into a highly
reactive and dynamic soundtrack created
by english custom music software so we
have a trailer you should take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
that was the english this is nicholas it
looks outstanding hello netflix
introduce yourself please what it is you
do and if you're feeling welcome
hopefully
oh yeah uh well i'm the game developer
and programmer and musician on england
and uh
yeah yeah i made a game together with my
friend swala sunberry who came up with
the graphical style
you have done an outstanding job like
you couldn't see my face on the screen
but the entire time i was watching that
trailer i sat like this
just like a mouth the gape looking at
the reactions and paul shack right there
and chad has the right of it i love any
games with reactive sounds like this and
i have to wonder with you and someone
else building a game like this
where do you even get the concept from
how does this start
oh it's uh we originally made a game at
the game jam so we created the original
version in 48 hours
and
the it was inspired by a swedish
artist who
wrote 10 comic books when he was 95
years old
good lord
that's really impressive inspired by art
see video games are art suck it critics
by the way it all looks so well and it
smooths like game jams are always
responsible for some amazing games as an
idea and then you just start thinking
wait what if we do this what if we do
this what if we add more so
tell us more about what we're seeing
right now and how you create this idea
of staying in the bubbles
uh
i think i came up with idea
by imagining echo the dolphin but
with these floating bubbles in the sky
instead of swimming in the water
funny thing is i've actually never
played that code dolphin so it's
inspired by something
i only have an idea in my head of
[Laughter]
that's the best source of inspiration
honestly ever i mean that's the same way
like i cook in the kitchen i'm like yeah
this is an aperitif right here inspired
by a recipe of a food i've never eaten
in my life so exactly obviously
you're doing something right because
everyone is wowed by what we're looking
at so how does this this custom
soundtrack work
it's uh basically i built the music
software and
the music software runs inside the game
itself
and that means that anything the music
software can do the game can also change
in the music
so you have levels where every time you
do a specific action the music changes
the key and the chords and stuff like
that
so
you're telling me in theory what i could
do once i've got a grasp of the game
is i could probably
put the game to the side play and create
my own soundtrack and just send it to
friends and say hey this is actually a
video game i was playing but check out
how cool it sounds
yeah yeah i mean i once did the dj set
where i played some of the music from
the game by playing the game
you
for real is an entire dj set
i was not only that but it was a part of
it
that is so creative like
that's such a brilliant idea dude to
just be in there djing like all right i
got a new track for y'all this is called
my game coming out pretty soon so please
buy it take a listen what a great
inspiration how how far into the game
were you well not you personally because
you made it but how parts of the game
was that period that you played
uh wait i didn't understand
well let's say there's like a level one
level two level three uh do you feel
like
yeah
and the game gets more groovy the
further into it you get
so the level i was djing was about
halfway through the game
okay that's a good point to go so all of
you out there watching right now i mean
if you're looking to get your dj skills
long you only gotta get half to the game
before you can be just like nicholas uh
often right now says the game looks
incredible sounds incredible and the dev
seems really friendly smiley face
but a very kind thing to say
yeah that's
that's actually really cool did you have
any kind of musical background when you
started this like there's the djing
obviously too but did you have any
inspirations as well for that
uh
i my musical background is i took a
bunch of years of piano lessons
and then i've been
making music
with computers since then
i love that that's exactly how like it's
two people right two-person team or
they're more yeah uh okay i mean i got
to help with porting and uh stuff from
triple topping
that's just so diy you know i want to do
this so i guess i'm going to learn how
to do this today oh now i know how to do
this great now i can put it in my game
what a great way to build a game like
this right
and people are saying this man is what i
aspire to be so obviously you're off to
a great start
yeah how hard was it to create the music
software for this game
uh
i think i was working on it as a side
project before i started the game and i
think
it took me two two years to develop
the board
i also used the same
music software an earlier version of it
in a previous game so i bring the same
software between games
well i mean all the work you put into it
and all the sculpting and educating of
yourself really showcases this so as
you're going to these levels if i'm
playing right now what am i looking to
do what's my indicator for progression
uh in this level you're supposed to go
in a circle and collect this collective
thing is
by reflecting yourself on walls and
stuff like that
um
yeah collect the thing is
collected thingies is exactly what echo
the dolphin is about so
even if you've never played it you're
right on course as to what the game
should be
uh it looks really good it looks
fantastic i i loved watching all of that
so
i guess i want to know
as you're winding down is there anything
that we didn't address that you want to
make sure everyone knows about this game
that we haven't discussed
uh
not not anything i can come up with
right now
okay just collect all the thingies enjoy
the music and all that good stuff maybe
send you some dj stuff along the way
your custom soundtracks too
yeah exactly
that's awesome
i love this game i love the idea of what
it is i love your genuine passion for
this you can tell by the excitement in
your face that you're really proud of
this project uh anytime like i said if i
see a game jam that turns into a real
game i know that game is put in work so
work in chat who's watching right now
follow updates on yang lit and find out
more information about the game or
you yeah
oh right you can find out
[Laughter]
well
there's the inlet website which is up
there in the top right corner and
i'm also on twitter on the name niflas
where i tweet a lot about uh
my development of various stuff and i
tweet a lot of england things there
okay so you can go there go to your
twitter
niff l-a-s-s
or yeah
or just one s okay go to your twitter
there for that or you can find out more
at england right there.com yngldt.com
dude this has been fantastic i love the
joy you bring this game's gonna be a
banger it's gonna be a hit
everyone's gonna enjoy it i can see it
already so thank you for taking time to
default information with us
yeah it was super fun to join in
ah thank you
that guy is awesome
like i love that guy he's so cool
like oh we got a full screen shot
perfect we're getting like this is like
behind the scenes footage right here you
know it's like a dvds collector's
edition
some of y'all don't know about that
because there's a lot of digital
streaming happening right but this is
like the back scene footage and the
extra footage and special features and
that kind of stuff and in case you
didn't hear of course you can go to
yangling.comglet.com to find out more
information or you can go to their
twitter
to find out more there as well
and
we're gonna have some more trailers and
more stuff happening and we actually
have one last set of trailers for you
all to look at
and
i know it's that part right it's the
last set of trailers but it hasn't been
a long period right id xbox has been
popping all day long so let's go ahead
and take a look that last set of
trailers
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how cool was that right i mean
was the last set of trailers for the day
yes is it sad maybe but are the games
dope yeah
they are and they looked really good too
listen i'm gonna point out one thing
really quickly well actually joe viola
says bro why that little turn up holding
the gun i love it because if you play
mario 2 sometimes you know what turn up
ain't enough you chuck those in a few
pow blocks and your man birdo is not
going down
so sometimes you need a little extra
turn up for turnip boy says odd quirk
yeah everyone came through for the
turnip stream an amazing cultivation
simulator i saw a moment where you could
draw a talisman and i got flashbacks to
okami
if you ever played that on the wii like
the yes those versions where you
actually use the drawing portion i love
any kind of game that includes that kind
of stuff
so i'm all then and as i always say
there's never a good time to say there's
nothing to play because based on that
there's everything to play
i actually want to see some more of
amazing cultivation simulator and maybe
you do too that's why we have hey kip
playing right now on their channel so
we're going to watch them
and see more of that video game stuff
and maybe you can watch too and then
they will come back and do some more
ideas xbox stuff i don't know stick
around and find out watch this
take your time buddy
[Music]
you you you've worked so hard
and you work so fast
you deserve some rest on a wooden bed
huh
just take your time what if we went a
little faster
okay that's faster what's the fastest
for you oh just rush to that bed you
know just rush to that bed take your
time and oh we're just working big time
over here just burying the dead bodies
of our enemies but you you get some good
rest okay
i guess you have more immortal friends
to help with attacks that's true
yeah okay even though this character is
essentially pointless this is just an
aesthetics character okay we have to
have a character just for aesthetics and
have our one little mortal wacky just
doing all the stuff we need
and then our god goes out and tells
people how cool we are
it's true what's up blues art
we're building okay now non here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna take this
body and you're gonna bury it where
should we even bury this body
where do you where should a cemetery
begin
maybe just like in this beautiful area
i don't know i don't where do you put a
dead body high rock high high
where where's the best place to put a
dead body
besides i guess a trunk of a car there's
no cars in this game i guess it's just
gonna be the ground they do love the
graves it's very they like the graves
is that a thing we can build
oh we can make a tomb okay okay we're
gonna build a tomb over here by this
beautiful turtle and hopefully you know
they're just gonna the spirits will love
that
and they won't
haunt me later
because i think that person was gonna
attack me i didn't i don't think i
killed an innocent person did i
i don't think i don't think i did
i don't think i did
because
their icon was red that red is bad red
is bad
but red means stop so should i stop
killing them
green means go means they're good
[Music]
do the cemeteries also need lanterns i
actually probably maybe maybe at least
one so it's not too dark
algo you're back alco you're having fun
oh welcome back oh god what why are you
spinning so fast what are you doing
oh my even on like normal speed
[Music]
what do you do
look at this like a little light show at
a rave it's like edm with this little
like just
octagonal hula hoop this is cool
[Music]
make a mausoleum for all of your enemies
yeah it'll be it'll be actually like a
tourist attraction and then we'll get
even more people to come here
but then maybe people want to come here
so that we just kill them
and i don't really want to have that be
the reputation of this town i want the
reputation of this town to be a bunch of
people playing tic-tac-toe by themselves
that's what i want this city to be known
by okay
is just loners playing a bunch of games
by themselves which i guess
you know is that relatable at all is
that relatable
i think so
but what if you played tic-tac-toe
together
robbing bandits kind of a great industry
really
so that should be our thing
not loner gamer town
we still have the dead body here i don't
okay non-sleeping okay so we're just
gonna let this hang out unless do you
want to bury can you how long is this
gonna take you let's see how long will
this take you well we have to build it
and that's gonna take too long so you
know what you go to bed you you did a
good walk you walked all the way up the
map and back and that's your day
why is it a decomposing i don't know if
things can decompose in this game oh
they can it just takes a long time
like i know other like food can
okay
i think it okay what's happening with
this corpse why is there a timer is this
for decomposing
okay let's just for those of you asking
that was amazing cultivation simulator
hey kip and this
this is id and xbox ball showcase
and just like an old cartoon used to say
bring games are now over this is over
too
that's the end of the show
i know i'm i'm sad too i don't have a
cardigan take on or put off but i'm
happy that you are all here today to
watch this with me i had a fantastic
time thank you everyone who tuned in to
the showcase shout outs to black girl
gamers for putting it down earlier love
that vibe love the chaos that happened
the entire time thank you to all the
devs and guests who join to share
updates on the games and if you're
watching you're like you know what
i'm a two-person team i have four years
of game study i want to put my own game
too you can submit your own game
if you want to do it for the id xbox
program you can visit xbox.com
id for details
and in case you didn't know the xbox
tokyo game show will be streaming on
september 15th at 6 00 pm jst 2 a.m
pacific that is 5 a.m eastern time
all of you saying such nice things to me
right now wow wow wow thank you there
have been a ton of indie games and i
look forward to a great deal of them uh
england looks fantastic nicholas was a
blast the entire time the ghostbusters
co-op session with jordan making me look
good
born of bread all right anytime anyone
tweets about paper mario it's
7 200 replies that are usually muted so
if you want something unique entailed to
that style indie base
that's an area you can navigate to as
well thank you to everyone at production
too there's an entire team behind all
this that you can't see or hear but they
make sure everything runs smoothly they
tell me when to say good job and want to
say shut up adrian
and thank all of you for being here all
of your comments down below and watching
the id at xbox you know and watching all
this cool stuff it means a lot
my name is ocadrian you may see more of
me in the future doing other hosting
stuff so stay tuned you can find me on
twitter at ocadrian
any place you want to look actually you
can find me adrian on twitch i've been
streaming for eight and a half years
partner for eight also a twitch
ambassador twitch.tv forward slash
ocadrian
i stream monday through
saturday tuesday through saturday i have
a schedule in fact i'll be live in like
two hours so thank all of you for tuning
in
we're gonna be raiding by the way hey
kip so if you enjoyed watching them play
you can watch some more so until next
time for the next id xbox showcase or
whenever we meet thank you for tuning in
make good choices and make sure to
follow the twitch gaming channel because
there's a ton of other shows that happen
bruce green cup of noodle john sandman
tons of people you love on twitch
just follow stay tuned and take care
thanks for watching
[Music]
you